hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompaña a ariel nieto el es ecuatoriano
y vivía en la ciudad ucraniana de rif
net desde hacía casi cuatro años así
estudiaba arquitectura y trabajaba
además como traductor y como modelo
cuando llegó la invasión rusa y con el
conflicto en este punto de extrema
violencia comenzó el camino para escapar
del país y regresar a ecuador un
recorrido plagado de dificultades
obstáculos y 10 por supuesto la
hostilidad propia de todas las guerras
haría el nieto muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en france 24
un gusto estar aquí el gusto es nuestro
de tenerte ariel bueno viviste como
decíamos en carne propia las
consecuencias de lo que es la guerra no
lo que te pasó a vos podría decirse que
es la propia guerra comencemos por aquel
dramático recorrido repleto de
dificultades de peligros no que tuviste
que vivir para escapar de la guerra en
ucrania contanos cómo comenzó cómo
fueron dándose todo
bueno creo que la guerra de ucrania
viene un largo tiempo simplemente
este hace 12 días que comenzó se ha
extendido lo que puede decir crear a las
armas yo me acuerdo que cuando comenzó
esto yo estaba durmiendo era a las 5 de
la mañana y mis padres desde ecuador me
llamaron me dijieron ariel están
atacando ucrania yo estaba durmiendo
colgué con ellos comencé a ver las
noticias y era verdad estaba rusia
estaba atacando la frontera de ucrania y
eso fue el comienzo de todo
prácticamente y
todo se fue alargando cuando los
soldados en cuestión de 12 días se
acercaban más y tomaban más ciudades
hasta que ya tienen prácticamente casi
toda ucrania dominada en este momento
contános ariel específicamente cómo fue
todo ese proceso no la huida sabemos que
tuviste que vivir episodios muy duros
si la verdad
poder salir de la ciudad escaso es muy
imposible taxis muy caros yo pagué 50
dólares por transportar me otra ciudad
tuvimos que pagar un bus que nunca salió
de 200 dólares por persona el cual nunca
llegó los trenes
no eran para extranjeros ni para hombres
no nos dejaban subirnos solo para
mujeres y niños cosa que nosotros para
poder llegar a la frontera tuvimos que
caminar casi 67 horas en lo que es nieve
a temperaturas menos cero a una
aclaración ariel estamos viendo
precisamente en estos momentos imágenes
que fueron grabadas por ti mismo durante
ese proceso cuando querían escapar bueno
como fue finalmente que lograron cruzar
la frontera
bueno nosotros tomamos un taxi y lo que
es el final de la fila de carros como
pueden ver en las imágenes carros que
llevan más de tres días ahí esperando
para poder llegar a la frontera tomamos
un taxi que nos dejó allí y caminamos
como les digo más de más de 20
kilómetros que son unas 67 horas
caminando hasta llegar al punto
fronterizo de polonia y lo hicieron en
condiciones extremas no se veía nieve
incluso en las imágenes que pudiste 2010
y una caminata comenzamos como las 3 de
la tarde y la caminata y salimos de la
frontera de polonia al día siguiente a
las 10 de la mañana hablas en plural
área alguien y te acompañaban
yo salí con un amigo pero en el proceso
de la caminata nos encontramos con más
ecuatorianos camine con la en la
frontera con 15 ecuatorianos pero al
momento de cruzar la frontera me
encontré con más ecuatorianos y
terminamos pasando la frontera juntos
más de 30 ahora me imagino que habrás
visto imágenes que difícilmente olvidará
es algo que movilizó te quedó marcado de
manera particular quizás
creo que una de las cosas que más duele
es ver como familias lloran en las
estaciones de trenes se despiden de las
esposas y de los hijos eso es muy muy
doloroso de ver
arjen un poco ya existe referencia a
esto al comienzo de la entrevista pero
te lo quiero preguntar de manera
particular cómo se vivían esos meses
previos no a la invasión donde todos
veíamos a lo largo de todo el mundo como
las tensiones iban creciendo cada vez
más
bueno realmente los ucranianos mismos no
creían que existía la guerra tu pregunta
vas a cualquier persona y todo lo que
decía no haber guerra russian no se va a
atacar no se va a atrever a atacar eras
algo que que nadie esperaba creo yo
nadie ni siquiera los mismos ucranianos
vamos más atrás en el tiempo ariel
porque como bien comentaba vos al
comienzo de la entrevista las tensiones
entre rusia y ucrania por supuesto no
son nuevas vienen de larga data como era
la vida antes de esta escalada del
conflicto el tema estaba presente
digamos en las vidas en las
preocupaciones de la población se
hablaba al respecto
es un problema prácticamente político
pero entre los ucranianos y rusos nunca
ha habido este problema nada no había
conflictos prácticamente todo era una
vida normal y buena
ariel y mantener contacto con gente que
hayas conocido hallada en ucrania que se
hayan quedado en territorio ucraniano y
si es así que te están contando
bueno yo tengo muchos amigos en mi
ciudad hombres y mujeres y estoy
constantemente escribiendo aquí cómo
están qué tal está la cosa allá y por
suerte la ciudad en la que yo viví que
el río no está siendo atacada en estos
momentos está todo bien que ellos dicen
cada uno un nuevo día gracias a dios que
seguimos vivos y por suerte en todos los
mis conocidos siguen sanos y a salvo
afortunadamente ojalá así siga siendo
bueno y ya te encontrás en ecuador'
estás en quito en tu país haría
contarnos cómo fue la llegada y si
recibiste algún tipo de ayuda por parte
del gobierno de lo largo de todo este
proceso hasta regresar finalmente a tu
tierra
bueno yo creo que ecuador como gobierno
no se hizo mucho presente en la etapa de
ucrania prácticamente para llegar a las
fronteras tuvimos que cada uno por sus
propios medios
hay personas que sufrieron más que yo
personas que sufrieron menos que yo pero
todos sufrimos a algún nivel cuando se
hizo más presente al momento de llegar a
polonia si nos ayudaron con hoteles y
con refugios
con el vuelo humanitario que nos trajo a
cada otra vez ecuador ariel como te
cambió la vida me imagino aunque ya no
sos el mismo que un tiempo atrás luego
de haber vivido y visto todo lo que
viste
bueno yo realmente estoy un poco triste
yo llegué a ecuador y mi reacción no fue
muy felices es lindo volver a su país
pero no que te que te has volver
prácticamente obligado por una guerra
que te está votando de una de otro país
que el cual tú ya consideraba es tu casa
que es triste bueno bueno está diciendo
que considerabas tu casa a ucrania no
bueno no sabemos qué va a suceder por
supuesto el deseo de todos es que
termine cuanto antes esta guerra pero
bueno en este contexto es una opción
regresar quizás a ucrania teniendo en
cuenta no en otro escenario por supuesto
y creo que tanto yo como todos los otros
ecuatorianos esperamos que se arregle
esto y tengamos la oportunidad de volver
a lo menos yo personalmente dejé pagando
el arriendo de mi departamento porque yo
confío que esto no se ve es tan largo
bueno eso te quería preguntar no lo más
vamos acomodar lo más práctico y
pragmático de la vida cotidiana tuviste
que escapar dejando todo apartamento
tengo entendido también una mascota
sí sí sí cuando sonaron las alarmas yo
llamé a mis amigos les dije que vamos a
hacer qué va a pasar me dijieron venga
acá vamos a salir a polonia hoy mismo yo
no estaba preparado cogí una maleta de
mochilero guardado guinness dos
pantalones dos camillas de un par de
zapatos cogí mi gato le dije a mi vecina
le dije por favor que se com y gato y
compre un taxi de 50 dólares a la ciudad
fronteriza
me imagino bueno todo a las apuradas
ariel ahora para los hombres era mucho
más difícil salir aunque para las
mujeres y niños allí tuviste que ver a
gente regresarse
si la verdad si los hombres los hombres
a lo menos hombres de 18 60 años no
tienen permitido salir del país y para
nosotros también como extranjeros es un
poco ese yo no creo no quiere decir odio
pero sí había preferido para hombres
para mujeres y niños y entonces creo que
para los extranjeros es un poco fue un
poco más difícil salir del país y de la
frontera ahora en medio de todo ese
periplo verdad que tuviste que vivir
para escapar de ucrania también te
encontraste con la solidaridad no de
muchísimas personas que te ayudaron
si tanto ucranianos y polacos muy muy
buenas personas en nuestro trayecto de
caminata de casi 20 km gente parada
en sus casas dando comida dando sabanas
dando agua y ayudando a las personas que
entienden que están escapando de una
guerra
bueno me decías recién que dejaste bueno
hablábamos de cosas que sean más
materiales no un apartamento una mascota
bueno la mascota no va por el lado
material pero que dejaste además de todo
eso en ucrania porque una parte de tu
vida habrá quedado allá
si es duro son cuatro años realmente una
vida formada una casa un trabajo
amigos experiencias cosas que no espero
yo recuperar
cuéntanos un poco más atrás incluso cómo
era tu vida así en ucrania
creo que yo vivía una ciudad pequeña la
verdad segunda vida muy tranquila muy
relajada con mis amigos en la mañana la
universidad de la tarde el trabajo la
noche descansar en casa una vida muy muy
tranquila muy normal se podría decir
bueno ariel estamos viendo movimientos a
lo largo de todo el mundo no esfuerzos
diplomáticos
acuerdos de alto el fuego que finalmente
no se cumplen como crees que va a
evolucionar todo esto más allá de tus
deseos no
bueno creo que es complicado ya yo no
quisiera hablar de política pero yo
espero que otros países puedan ayudar a
ucrania porque
rusia es un país muy grande muy fuerte y
si ucrania no tiene ayuda a nada no creo
que nadie pueda parar a putin más que
rusia
bueno ariel por último un mensaje para
los ecuatorianos que se encuentran
todavía así para todos los que no son
ucranianos y que se encuentran en
ucrania que les diría teniendo en cuenta
tu experiencia
si deciden no salir del país
cuídense ayuden a las personas que
pueden y si deciden seguir del país
espero que puedan hacerlo con seguridad
yo sé que tanto ustedes como yo
esperamos que esto acabe rápido
ariel muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia durante todos estos minutos en
la entrevista de france 24 en español ha
sido un placer dialogar contigo
igualmente muchas gracias gracias a ti
nuevamente a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a seguir
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación recuerden además que pueden
volver a ver esta entrevista y muchas
más en nuestra página web france24
puntocom gracias por acompañarnos y
sigan con nosotros
[Música]